avec nous pour en parler alexandre
vincent deh vous êtes le maire et
républicains de rillieux-la-pape près de
lyon françois cocq enseignants et
céistes ancien maire-adjoint de
champigny sur marne
bonsoir à tous les deux messieurs merci
d'être avec nous je le disais alexandre
vincent des kills maire qui a déclenché
la polémique 1 depuis 24 heures en tout
cas le débat après plusieurs épisodes de
violence un urbaine et de menaces dans
votre ville monsieur le maire vous avez
décidé d'agir vous appelez vos
administrés à dénoncer les délinquants
via la nouvelle plate forme de
signalement de la police nationale
expliquez-nous votre démarche
le démarche est assez simple heures
après ou connaissez l'emballement
médiatique c'est que on commence à
expliquer un peu les choses et puis tout
de suite on entend les mots outranciers
avec la référence aux heures les plus
sombres de notre histoire avec la
délation
on est pas du tout là dedans vous savez
j'étais sur le ces dernières semaines à
rillieux la pape comme ailleurs en
france il ya actuellement des violences
urbaines ces violences urbaines où on a
sorti des véhicules où on s'attaque aux
forces de police
j'ai vécu moi bien mal puisque j'ai été
jusqu'à encore trois heures du matin
samedi dernier sur le terrain auprès des
habitants et aux côtés des policiers des
forces de vente
est ce que j'ai pu constater au delà de
ce qu'on voit sur les images de caméras
de vidéoprotection
c'est au delà de la violence c'est pour
parfois le jeune âge de certains des des
personnes qui s'adonnaient à ces
violences
et moi ce qui m'a ce qui m'a choqué je
viens quand je suis rentré chez moi
samedi soir j'ai très peu d'armes très
peu dormi
d'abord par colère vis-à-vis des
habitants et à cause de ces violences
mais aussi en disant mais comment des
jeunes aussi jeunes peuvent-ils
peuvent-ils continuer comme ça et
comment vont-ils finir et au bout du
compte je me suis dit finalement il faut
aussi en appeler à la responsabilité de
chacun et premièrement des parents le
vrai sujet qu'on a aujourd'hui
si vous avez des très jeunes dans les
quartiers qui notamment depuis le
premier confinement ont été pris en main
par les plus anciens les plus âgées qui
sont souvent de jeunes majeurs ces
jeunes majeurs sont souvent en lien avec
le trafic de stupéfiants 32
et il utilise avec un cynisme absolu les
plus jeunes
les mineurs qui l'ont récupérée pour
certains par les premiers confinement et
ils s'en servent ils s'en servent
excusez moi l'expression comme de la
chair à canon et ces jeunes quand il y
en a qui ont parfois 12 13 14 ans moi je
me refuse à faire en sorte qu'on les
abandonne savez je pars du principe que
ceux qui peuvent nous aider
aux côtés des collectivités et forces de
l'ordre de la justice essaie de les
remettre dans le droit chemin et en tout
cas faire en sorte qu'il ne brise pas
leur destin ce sont avant tout les
parents
personne ne s'offusque quand vous voyez
une jeune femme se faire agresser dans
la rue ou comme on l'a vu récemment à
paris se faire violer personne ne
s'offusque que vous appelez les forces
de l'ordre pour faire ce signalement
pour appeler à l'aide
parce qu'il ya assistance à personne en
danger quand vous êtes chez vous et que
vous entendez à côté de la paroisse dans
l'appartement d'à côté travers la paroi
de votre hymne de votre appartement
un père de famille violer son enfant ou
passé à tabac s'accompagne et bien vous
prenez votre téléphone
et puis vous appelez les services de
secours pour les renseigner pour leur
demander d'intervenir il ya je pense que
c'est exactement la même chose pour les
jeunes mineurs qui aujourd'hui sont 30 à
en train de tomber dans l'ultra violence
le but est bien de ces petits de leur
porter assistance
parce que le vrai sujet c'est de sauver
ses enfants françois cocq c'est bien
effectivement de s'expliquer parce que
comme disait monsieur le maire on rentre
vite dans les polémiques et les
jugements à l'emporte-pièce
d'une certaine manière c'est aussi une
assistance à personne en danger certains
jeunes qui pourraient gâcher leur vie
redevenant des criminels en faisant
pardon de l'expression un jour une
connerie
qu'est ce que vous en pensez l'idée
forcément mauvaise écoute et si je peux
partager le constat de monsieur le maire
je suis j'ai été élu à champigny j'ai
toujours enseignants dans l'un de ces
quartiers qui est l'un de ceux dans
lesquels il ya une vie particulièrement
active et malheureusement nous avons
payé un lourd tribut encore ces derniers
jours à champigny sur marne avec le
décès de plusieurs jeunes mais toujours
est il que si on peut partager le
constat je ne partage pas l'analyse
c'est à dire que l'enseignant que je
suis ce qu'il a sous les yeux quand il
voit un enfant dysfonctionné ça traduit
à chaque fois je le dis bien à chaque
fois un dysfonctionnement de la cellule
familiale
derrière et donc se tourner
immédiatement vers les parents en leur
disant à vous de faire le boulot
derrière avoue de reprendre les choses
en main tout cela fonctionnerait si les
parents est en capacité de le faire
la vérité du ctif c'est qu'ils ne le
sont pas et s'ils ne le sont pas c'est
qu'il ya besoin dans ce cas-là
d'intermédiation et le problème de ces
quartiers que vous évoquez monsieur le
maire c'est que d intermédiation qui
sont de fait les services publics la
police la justice l'éducation tendez le
bien les collectivités territoriales
avec ce que vous devez j'imagine mettre
en place dans votre ville et ce qui est
le cas dans toutes les villes dans
lesquelles il ya les dyades il ya des
quartiers populaires et bien tout cela
aujourd'hui est insuffisant parce que
ces zones ne sont pas les territoires
perdus de la république
ce sont des territoires de relégation
acial sociales géographiques économiques
mais aussi des territoires de relégation
pour les services publics et donc la
prise en charge doit aussi s'organiser
ce ne sont ce n'est pas parce qu'il ya
un manquement de l'état aujourd'hui là
dedans que l'on peut dire aux citoyens
qu'ils doivent se saisir de cette
question et je le dis en ajoutant un
dernier mot c'est qu'on vient de voir le
reportage qui a précédé notre notre
discussion
dans celui ci on voit des choses
extrêmement dangereuses et malsaines
dans ce pays l'opposition entre la
police et la justice
je viens de voir qu'ils un sondage qui
vient de sortir et qui a été réalisé par
doxa qui voudraient opposer l'un et
l'autre on voudrait opposer de manière
manichéenne la sécurité et la liberté
je crois que l'on ne s'en sortira pas 6
on procède de la sorte est aujourd'hui
en l'appel que vous lancez aux parents
et d'une manière plus générale au
citoyen est un appel qui contribuent à
ce climat ambiant dans le sens où ce
n'est pas à l'individu qu'il faut en
appeler c'est aux citoyens or le citoyen
il est membre de la communauté politique
et il faut que l'on continue à regarder
notre voisin en égal en citoyenneté en
égalant citoyenneté et non pas en un
individu qui potentiellement pourrait
être soit fautif soit délateur donc je
pense que c'est une perte dans laquelle
il ne faut pas apporter de l'eau aux
vents mauvais qui sont ceux qui déjà
aujourd'hui traverse notre pays
alexandre vincent deh il ya aussi l'idée
qu'ils aient vécu et dans votre
initiative dans votre proposition d'un
état finalement impuissant
non cela strictement rien à voir en fait
d'ailleurs je mon interlocuteur déjà où
il ya deux choses qui me choquent
premièrement qui nous dit qu'il faut
surtout faut surtout ne rien dire braves
gens dormez tranquilles ne déposez
jamais plainte si vous voyez une
agression détourner le regard
si vous voyez qu'un jeune est en grande
difficulté ne dit rien mais c'est dans
quel monde on vit
mais il ya malgré moi monsieur le maire
mais je veux faire remarquer que cette
coopération sur la question juste si
vous m'aimez pas coupé donc je pense qu
en cours vous n'avez pas que vos élèves
des coupe la parole et je pense que ça
serait bien que vous puissiez prendre
l'appareil s'il vous plaît comme ça on
aura un dialogue constructif et au poids
on pourra échanger nos arguments mais en
attendant c'est ce que vous avez dit si
je peux juste en placer une
m'excuser parce que sinon si vous prenez
juste la parole et puis que vous êtes
vous ne vous n'aimez pas la
contradiction ça va poser un problème
dans le débat et de compréhension de la
part des téléspectateurs
je dis simplement que y'a un moment
justement un citoyen d'ailleurs ça y est
vous en tant que mère par exemple
l'article 40 du code pénal
j'ai des responsabilités si par exemple
j'ai connaissance d'un délit et bien si
je ne leur si je n'affirme pas la
justice où les forces de l'ordre je suis
pénalement responsable quand vous êtes
parent ou quand vous êtes un citoyen qui
voit qu'un enfant est en train de
commettre des choses qui sont
délictuelle votre devoir de citoyen
notamment sur un enfant pour qu'on
puisse le sauver pour qu'on puisse
intervenir pour qu'on puisse cesser la
violence
et bien c'est un moment et bien se
tourner vers les institutions et
notamment vers la police et la justice
aidée des collectivités savez dans ces
quartiers vous dites ah mais non ces
cartes qui il ya des dysfonctionnements
etc
attendez qu'on va arrêter juste trente
secondes la caricature oui dans ses
quartiers à de grandes difficultés
je suis maire depuis maintenant sept ans
et j'ai lancé un des plus grand plan de
rénovation urbaine de l'agglomération
lyonnaise on est en train de refaire les
écoles on a lancé et on a ouvert il ya
moins il ya un peu plus d'un mois une
médiathèque flambant neuf où on va avoir
une exposition d'envergure nationale
dans l'est dans les mois qui viennent on
met en place énormément de dispositifs
et dans ces quartiers je peux vous le
dire il ya des gens extraordinaires
bien sûr qu'ils sont en grande
difficulté sociale bien sûr qu'il ya des
mères de famille seules celles qui
viennent par l'ong sur le sur le plateau
qui aujourd'hui nous invite qui parfois
viennent très tôt sont des mères de
familles parfois seuls qui se lève à 4
heures du matin pour venir faire le
ménage et qui ne voient pas leurs
enfants partir à l'école il ya des
personnes qui ce seuil au 80 dans ces
quartiers pour pouvoir faire en sorte
que leurs enfants réussissent et ses
enfants moi je les vois il compose la
majorité des habitants de ces quartiers
des familles qui font tout pour que
leurs enfants réussissent un cerf
éduquent leurs enfants parce qu'ils ont
compris qu'en tant que parent leur
première responsabilité est d'assurer
d'assurer l'éducation et l'avenir de
leurs enfants
au delà de ça il ya des parents qui
peuvent être sincèrement difficulté et
je rencontre chaque semaine cela moi je
le dis si vous avez besoin d aide
nous vous tendons la main pour qu'on
puisse y ont sauvé votre enfant mais au
delà sarre en tant que parent si voyez
votre enfant des rires il est aussi de
votre responsabilité de vous reprendre
notre moi je vais prendre l'exemple de
la maman de la petite marguerite qui
était cette maman qui était d'une
dignité extraordinaire alors que sa
fille venait de se faire poignarder par
un jeune adolescent de 13 14 ans savait
elle n'a pas accusé la justice
elle n'a pas accusé la police elle n'a
pas accusé de nice de l'intérieur au
ministre de la justice sur la société
dans son ensemble
ça nous on essaie de se décharger de
tout elle a dit simplement et au les
parents et les vos enfants occupez vous
de vos enfants demander où sont ils de
soir mais c'est ça le vrai message vous
trouvez normal quand on est parents
qu'on ne se comporte comme un géniteur
moi je trouve pas moi je suis désolé
mais dans les quartiers j'en parlais
encore avec une association aujourd'hui
quand vous avez
enfant de seulement 3 ans ou quatre ans
qui sont laissés seuls dans la rue et
que les acteurs sociaux se retrouve à
gérer ces enfants qui sont quasiment
abandonné mais dites nous en tant que
citoyens et acteurs publics
mais notre devoir c'est de faire des
signalements avant je faisais pas de
signalement sur les femmes battues
maintenant on le fait on ne faisait pas
de signalement sur l'inceste
maintenant le fait il serait peut-être
temps aussi de le faire pour les enfants
qui aujourd'hui sont abandonnés il
serait peut-être temps aussi connaît un
nécessaire sursaut parental parce que le
vrai sujet c'est qu'on doit travailler
bien sûr avec les collectivités la
police la justice et c'est un continuum
de notre sécurité mais aussi un
continuum de responsabilités y compris
dans ces quartiers hélas en aux parents
et les citoyens prennent toute leur
place avec anna citoyens qui colle aux
abords des grands prix vont vos deux
messages en tout cas et et vos points de
vue j'aurais faire avancer un peu ce
débat dans l'allier un certainement de
ce que vous proposez depuis le 4 mars
dernier une plate forme et met à
disposition des citoyens pour s'y noyer
s'est signalé pardon cette fois les
points de deal un gérald darmanin avait
expliqué sa démarche au parisien à
l'époque les citoyens doivent être actif
dans ce combat contre la drogue mais
nous devons leur donner les moyens de
nous aider en gros françois cocq c'est
toujours la même chose il ya une forme
d'impuissance de la part des services de
l'état et désormais on en appelle aux
citoyens vous le lisez comme ça non
cette interprétation est beaucoup trop
facile
s'il ya une puissance de l'état c'est
que ceci a été organisé depuis des
années enfin qui a organisé la casse de
la police républicaine dans ce pays qui
a limité les effectifs qui a fait des
regroupements de deux zones de sécurité
qui sont absurdes et qui sont
déconnectés du terrain tout ce qu'on
connaît depuis maintenant une quinzaine
d'années et qu'on connaît surtout nos
territoires
donc aujourd'hui l'impuissance de l'état
a été organisé et on glisse et aux
citoyens d'agir
eh bien il ya là un vrai danger et je
suis désolé mais votre intervention
monsieur le monsieur le maire en atteste
vous avez commencé à vous dire c'est aux
parents d'agir et puis immédiatement
vous avez dit c'est aux citoyens de
venir agir et de dénoncer mais là on
rentre dans un jeu extrêmement dangereux
s'ils vivent
ah ça nous ne pouvons pas nous passer
aujourd'hui d'une interne et une
intermédiation qui permettrait de
concilier la force et le droit c'est
tout le rôle c'est toute la construction
de la police républicaine depuis plus de
deux siècles dans ce pays est
aujourd'hui nous pourrions rentrer dans
un modèle complètement à l'anglo saxonne
où nous comporterons comme des individus
atomisés en train en train de regarder
l'un et l'autre en chiens de faïence je
crois que c'est une grave erreur et que
les manquements de l'état ne peuvent pas
aujourd'hui être compensée par les
citoyens nous sommes dans un moment on a
besoin d'une refondation républicaine et
d'une refondation populaire chacun le
voit bien et s'ils ne viennent bien
mauvaise manière de s'y prendre que
d'une certaine manière de permettre aux
citoyens d'être monter les uns contre
les autres
vous savez les sujets excusez moi mais
si je peux juste répondre moi vous savez
je vais pas partir dans les grands
débats philosophiques ou des grands
débats partisans aux séries je vais
peut-être beaucoup moins intelligent
vous est beaucoup moins instruits c'est
vrai mais j'ai quand même une certaine
expérience de terrain le savez il ya
quinze jours je vais vous raconter une
petite expérience il ya quinze jours on
a réussi à nettoyer un point de lille
complètement et à mettre en prison ceux
qui s'adonnaient au trafic de
stupéfiants et qui essayait de mettre en
couple régler plusieurs immeubles
ça faisait plus d'un an qu'on travaille
avec les habitants et grâce pour
remonter l'information des habitants
non pas que la police n'a pas les moyens
d'avoir des informations mais la police
ça si on met un policier dans la cage
d'escalier le dealer il ira dans une
autre cage d'escalier donc on devra
mettre un policier dans chaque cage
d'escalier ça c'est juste pas possible
vous n'avez aucun état par un état
totalitaire qui qui peut il réussir à
faire ça donc on a travaillé avec les
citoyens on à travers des choses que je
peux voir et ils nous en donner des
éléments derrière nous avons pu
déclencher une enquête judiciaire
il ya eu enquête interpellations des
ferments condamnation et emprisonnements
et on a travaillé tous ensemble qu'ils
voulaient aujourd'hui les gens nous
remercient
ça veut dire que les citoyens ont joué
leur rôle et d'ailleurs c'est inscrit
dans la loi dans la constitution comme
vous êtes visiblement très inspiré je
vous invite à aller à retourner la lire
et vous verrez que sept inscrits en tant
que citoyens nous avons tous un rôle à
jouer
respawn question de délation quand on
essaie justement de mettre par terre un
trafic de drogue
je pense que justement si on arrive à
voir ce lien de confiance entre la
police et les citoyens c'est plutôt
quelque chose de constructif pas par
ailleurs à la justice
ça fait son travail et les trafiquants
ou été mis en prison et vous voyez
depuis quinze jours
et bien alors qu'ils ont connu un an
d'enfer et ben les habitants depuis
quinze jours peut vivre de nouveau en
paix c'est simplement un exemple pour
montrer que quand on s'y met tous quand
on rame où tous dans le même sens eh
bien on peut y arriver
et par ailleurs je pense que dans cette
société il faut qu'on arrête d'être
consommateurs de tout on peut pas être
que consommateur de la sécurité ont
d'être acteurs de la cité
vous devrez quand des citoyens
responsables et éclairé et à partir de
là et bien là avec 30 secondes avec les
caricatures de on était dans la balance
son port après valence la mer est
maintenant balances ton voisin ça marche
pas tout à fait comme ça parce que
désolé on va arrêter dans ce pays
à chaque fois de tout caricaturer avec
d'un côté ceux comme vous qui l'isolent
info strictement rien dire et foster
donc à ce constat la débrouille et plus
d'avoir joué dans laquelle j'avais sur
la caricature litres et de l'autre côté
excusez moi et de l'autre côté ceux qui
disent allez les gamins de 11 14 15 ans
tous en tôle et on y brise nombreux
jeunes excusez moi je pense juste qu'au
mieux on peut parler de
responsabilisation de citoyenneté et
essayer aussi de sauver des gosses qui
aujourd'hui sont pris en main par des
caïds de quartier par des dealers qui
deale de la mort et qui utilisent ces
gamins comme de la chair à canon bah moi
je suis désolé je préfère en tant que
citoyen et en tant que père de famille
me dire que ces enfants on peut
peut-être encore les sauver et pour les
sauver eh bien il faut casser
aujourd'hui cette spirale de la violence
chez moi dans ma crainte c'est qu'ici on
ne fait rien demain quelqu'un peut
rester sur le carreau
ça peut être un jeu ne sabotent un
policier mais je vous ça arrivera il
sera trop tard pour pleurer
françois quand le mot de la fin
rapidement c'est vous le pouvez merci
non je crois que malheureusement
beaucoup de jeunes reste déjà
aujourd'hui sur le carreau on en a de
trop triste exemple
et je crois que les informations on les
a si la police aujourd'hui n'a pas les
informations sur les endroits où se
déroulent les trafics de drogue c'est
que quelque chose ne fonctionne pas dans
la police ce n'est pas vrai qu'on a
besoin aujourd'hui de citoyens pour
aller savoir que si dans l ogre dentelle
hall chacun le sait je vois dans les
quartiers qui sont autour de moi
la police sait très bien où agir temps
agir comment coco mots comment agir il
n'y a pas besoin de mêlée aujourd'hui
les citoyens sans les citoyens ont droit
aux droits imprescriptibles de l'homme
effectivement c'est la sécurité et pour
ça c'est à la police de faire son
travail et qu'on lui en donne les moyens
qu'on arrête de
des membres et d'un côté et de dire aux
gens finalement débrouillez-vous il faut
que vous rentrez entriez dans une guerre
de tous contre tous genres se
débrouiller mais aucun moment mais
attendez nous dans nos quartiers la
police fait son travail en des moyens
supplémentaires qui sont arrivés alors
arrêté 30 secondes de caricaturer enfin
si on pouvait juste arrêté dans ma vie
il ya les jours une position s'est
retrouvé avec 90 donc un moins de moyens
excusez moi moi dans ma commune depuis
que je suis arrivé d'augmenter le nombre
de policiers augmenté nombre de caméras
et jeu des policiers nationaux
supplémentaires parce que je me suis
battu et donc les moyens quand on veut
on peut
et c'est aussi ça la force de
l'engagement politique merci en tout cas
tous les deux on aura compris vos
opinions respectives irréconciliables ce
soir mais c'est la force du face-à-face
merci à vous deux alexandre vincent d et
françois cocq sida